crece la frustración en el Líbano
cientos de personas se manifestaron A
las afueras de los bancos de beirut la
capital libanesa en contra de las
restricciones informales sobre los
retiros de efectivo el deterioro de las
condiciones económicas del país y el
último desploma histórico de la libre
libanesa
que están esperando ustedes libaneses
para bajar y quitarle sus derechos a
esta mafia de ladrones y criminales que
está gobernando dónde están los Derechos
Humanos no hay electricidad ni agua nada
de nada en este país cuál
ha sido no sienten a la gente nos ven
como ovejas no nos quedaremos callados
sobre el valor de nuestra vida
desde 2019 los bancos libaneses
impusieron restricciones a los retiros
de Divisas las cuales nunca fueron
reguladas por la ley por lo que los
depositantes se ven obligados a retirar
su dinero a través de juicios e incluso
a la fuerza motivando a muchos a
mantener meses de protestas constantes
Además este 16 de febrero se conoció que
la libre libanesa ha perdido más del 98%
de su valor Durante los últimos cuatro
años cotizándose en 80.000 libras por un
dólar en el mercado negro tan solo dos
días después de que ya registrará otro
récord al alcanzar 70.000 libras por
dólar
algunas personas fueron millonarias en
dólares pero no tienen ni un centavo en
el bolsillo porque los bancos se robaron
todo y se están beneficiando del
corrupto sistema Estatal y Judicial para
ocultar este crimen a plena luz del día
[Música]
El Banco Central del país ha guardado
silencio sobre la crisis y no ha dicho
si está tomando medidas para abordar el
problema que parece estar lejos de ser
solucionada